[Music]  looks like a brand-new Ben Affleck was  snapped in Santa Monica California over  the weekend looking happy and healthy  I feel great this is really exciting it  appears the father of three has turned a  new leaf since he wrapped up rehab on  Wednesday a source close to the actor  told et Ben is doing great  he is still very taken aback by the out  point of support since making his very  personal announcement as always he's  enjoying spending time with his children  and Friends in mid-march Affleck  revealed he had completed treatment for  alcohol addiction writing I'm lucky to  have the love of my family and friends  including my co-parent Jen how do you  make all that work I mean you guys got a  lot going on new door bus at the time a  source explained Det Ben did this for  himself but noted family always comes  first  [Music]  you  [Music]